Kourtney Kardashian recently posted a
cute farm pic to Instagram and the pic
has people talking big time I love it
let's rewind shall we on Sunday court
shared this snap to social media that's
the reality star holding a baby goat
rocking jeans and a flannel innocent
enough right well not so fast
some eagle-eyed fans were quick to
recognize that oversized shirt and point
it out that courts ex Scott Disick has
the same one
not only that they found this pic of
Scott wearing the shirt with his now
ex-girlfriend Sofia Richie on a date in
2017
just to recap Scott and Sophia split
last month after almost three years
together Scott and Kourtney called it
quits in 2015 after almost a decade of
dating and have three kids together 10
year-old Mason seven year old Penelope
and five year old rain I mean I think
you just gotta figure out really what's
important to you at the end of the day
last year court sister Khloe and Scott
sat down with et Coco gave the former
couple mad props for their co parenting
skills it's hard work for all parties
and I think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
I'm gonna play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
and love is love and I'm so proud of
them it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that the two are still super involved in
each other's lives and Scott is a staple
on Keeping Up with the Kardashians
but anyway back to that mystery flannel
naturally fans are wondering if Kourt
rockin Scotts shirt is a sign that the
two could be back on the exes are
currently on vacation together in
Wyoming along with Kourt sisters Kylie
and Kim and last month the two went on a
family vacay with the kids to Utah
a few days after the kardashian-jenner
is reunited to celebrate Scott's
birthday with a small get-together at
home okay so while it's on
clear of Scot in court are back together
one thing seems to be for certain Court
is by his side no matter what
in May he learned that Scot had recently
checked himself in and out of a Colorado
rehab facility at the time a source told
ET that both sophia and court were big
proponents of Scot seeking treatment
again ET source added that Scot has
struggled with these issues for a while
and although he was previously doing
well it was time for him to get help
again
it was definitely a process when ET sat
down with Scott last year he opened up
about what matters most through the ups
and downs I mean there's so many
different things that can pull you in
different directions and you could look
online and Instagram social meaning all
these things but at the end of the day I
mean you just want to be happy you want
to be content
[Music]